how's married life i have to wear this
thing now
you know it's just surreal man sam
askari talking married life with britney
spears for the first time it's amazing
it's heaven from here on out in his
first interview since their june 9th
wedding sam dished to abc's will reeve
all about their big day it's been a
minute it was way overdue for us and uh
we imagined this thing being a fairy
tale and it was and we only had like 50
to 70 people we wanted to just celebrate
uh and that's what we did and how's brit
feeling about being a married woman
she's amazing she's doing great she's my
wife
but is that what does that feel like to
be like she's my wife yeah it hasn't hit
me yet you know i'm not like i it hasn't
the husband thing hasn't hit me yet like
sam mentioned their june wedding was an
intimate one at their home in thousand
oaks california and included many a-list
guests like selena gomez madonna drew
barrymore and paris hilton who just told
et the highlight of the night for her
just
her walking down the aisle and just
seeing this the sparkle in her eyes and
you know more than anyone she deserves
this happy ending and her freedom and it
just represented so much like it was
just
such a beautiful intimate affair and it
was unforgettable in a fairy tale and i
was just so proud to be there for her as
for what's next for the couple sam's
focused on work he's got a new movie hot
seat coming out this has a bones pick
with the city let's discuss asset
elimination
want you ready to put it and he slapper
now he was working as an actor long
before he met britt but sam doesn't
discount how his wife has helped him i
didn't really get noticed until you know
my wife gave me like this amazing
platform to work with so i'm always
appreciated of that but let's not take
away from the fact that i've been
working hard and i was already acting i
don't take any opportunity that i have
as
for granted
and i really try to
stay positive with everything that's
happening in fact sam says he even draws
inspiration from the pop star in her
career just being in a relationship with
someone that has achieved so much
so many great things and
at such a young age
kind of gives me
the understanding and and and teaches me
so much for the little things i'm gonna
achieve what are the big things god
knows what it's up to me what does
britney say to you when you need
encouragement to go out and achieve your
dreams she kind of says go go get it
and at the end of the day sam just wants
to make his future family proud i want
to be able to make my children or my
future children happy
and they'll be like oh that's my dad i
want to be like my dad you know at the
end of my life i want to be able to have
a great career but more importantly i
want people to look up to me that my
loved ones my children my wife you know
things like that
[Music]